yes and that is similarly similarly can
you say similarly say it similarly good
similarly similarly similarly now it
gets harder more you do it say toy booat
five times fast toy boo toy boo toy
booat toy boo toy boo pretty good toy
boat toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat
toy boat toy oh my gosh so do you like
Fantastic Mr Fox have you read this for
a long time but I haven't I don't know
Mr Fox and the nox on the socks has a
box with the thing and the it's just I
mean like they're crazy abs you know
this one the big black bug bit the big
black bear and the big black bear blood
BW black blood no because I didn't study
so I don't know all these things that
people would do they' all have these
like you know these tongue twisters that
they would do and I would just like you
know walk on set and be like I guess
I'll try